موسم عمر ضخم ستشهد مكه المكرمه مع حلول
شهر رمضان حيث كشفت الهيئه الملكيه لمكه
المكرمه والمشاعر المقدسه عن تخصيص 400
حافله لنقل المعتمرين والزوار بشكل مجاني
اكثر من سبعه ملايين راكب من المتوقع ان
تنقلهم الحافلات المخصصه عبر 438 محطه
موزعه في احياء مكه ما يعني ان اعداد
الركاب اليوميه ستتجاوز 230 الف راكب
ارقام الحافلات وركاب في رمضان لهذا العام
تعد اكبر بخمسه اضعاف من العام الماضي
وكانت انذاك عدد الحافلات 80 حافله فقط
من احدى محطات النقل العام في مكه ينضم
الينا مراسل عربيه سلطان السلمي سلطان
مرحبا بك كل سنه وانت طيب كيف ستبدو
الرحله اليوم بالنسبه للمعتمر والزائر في
رمضان هذا العام عبر حافلات النقل الجماعي
[موسيقى]
امامنا نشاهد بشكل كبير جدا اعداد ضخمه من
المعتمرين يحرصون على التنقل عبر هذه
الحافلات المزوده باعلى التقنيات
والامكانيات ووسائل الراحه وكذلك مزوده
بالكاميرات والانترنت وايضا كافه الوسائل
العامله لايصال المعتمرين من والى المحطات
كذلك نتحدث على ارقام كبيره شهدها هذا
العام نتحدث على اكثر من 37 مليون شخص
استفاد من حافلات مكه في شهر مارس فقط
وهذا رقم يعتبر كبير جدا لاسيما انه مكه
المكرمه تشهد ازدحامات
بشريه كبيره من قبل المؤتمرين والمصلين في
هذه المنطقه المحطات تتشر عبر 12 مسار في
في اغلب الاماكن الاكثر حيويه وزياره من
قبل معتمرين المصلين ايضا هنالك 12 مصادر
يتحدث بطول يصل الى
560 كيلو متر عبر 438 محطه ارقام كبيره
تعمل عليها حافلات لذلك تعتمد القطاعات
الامنيه او الجهات الخدميه في الحرم المكي
الاعتماد بشكل كبير جدا على هذه الحافلات
في خطط نقلهم للمعتمرين المصلين طوال شهر
رمضان من والى الحرم المكي وكذلك التنقل
الى المرافق السكنيه الخاصه بالمعتمرين
لذلك يحرص المعتمر القادم من الخارجة وحتى
من الداخل ان يعني يقوم بركوب هذه الحافله
المزوده بمقاعد لذوي الاحتياجات الخاصه
وكذلك هنالك امكانيات كبيره داخل هذه
الحافله الاستفاده منها بشكل مجاني كما
تشاهدون اعداد كبيره وازدحامات كبيره تشهد
هذه المنطقه لا سيما مع قرب دخول شهر
رمضان نعم